so I'm supposed to find the shadow came
from inside a daiquiri pretty sure we
can shave your head don't touch my head
everybody its charlie past the waffles
because Legion is back and we have the
craziest of openers to talk about I got
so many questions about this what's
going on what are they implying it's not
quite as confusing as it seems they did
a pretty good job of explaining all that
missing time at the very end of the
episode if you are brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's gonna be a ton
of Marvel dropping between infinity war
and Deadpool in the next couple of
months so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet also added bonus
there's ten episodes this season instead
of eight like last season so I'll try to
explain what the video schedules gonna
be at the end of this because as you
could tell from crazy astral plane dance
battles Legion is a very different kind
of superhero show I wouldn't even call
it a superhero show so let's just start
with the big stuff first I'll go through
my normal top 10 but there's way more
stuff to talk about so I'll try to
squeeze it all in but starting with the
big thing first that opening narration
in the montage so you may have detected
the familiar voice of the narrator sort
of like a Rod Serling thing going on
there is a maze in the desert carved
from sand and rock a vast labyrinth of
pathways and corridors that's Jon Hamm
from Mad Men the Creator was like I met
him a little while ago I needed someone
to do these educational voiceovers as he
calls them and Jon Hamm was like yeah
sure of course I'll do it so Jon Hamm is
gonna be doing this throughout the
season don't know how long they booked
him for could be for the entire season
so we might get these Jon Hamm scenes
where he explains concepts every single
week his voiceover is mostly talking
about how David is still tied up with
the shadow King on a psychic level like
even though his body is elsewhere
they're still communicating with each
other on a certain level and because of
that big WTF at the end we actually
learned that he's helping him a little
bit but like the way they opened the
episode talking about getting lost in
the maze of your own mind it's all about
David being this insane character from
the comics that gets lost within the
maze of his own mind as he goes deeper
and deeper into the psychic realms in
the astral plane but it's also a nice
way to talk about what's going on with
Oliver's character too because you see
him a couple times during the episode so
the opening montage over that voice over
where the camera pulls away from Oliver
in the pool although
out to him in present day you see the
new actor playing a mall Farook sitting
in a chair in what looks like Paris in
one of the levels of his mind it's just
a way to show you how the shadow king is
in control of Oliver's body and he's
also keeping Lennie in these other
personalities at bay the funny thing
here though is is what's going on with
Lenny's character because technically
Lennie is the Shadow King
but it's another version of the Shadow
King when he was still in David's mind
so don't drive yourself too crazy trying
to figure everything out but the big
dance battle so we got to talk about
that and the club and what it represents
they actually found David's physical
body in a club somewhere that looks like
the club that they have that dance
battle and so there's like a psychic
representation of the club that
represents when he's talking and
communicating with the Shadow King so
early in the episode the first time you
see him try to follow this person who is
the Shadow King like his true form
you see Lenny and Oliver stand up to
block his way that's basically the
Shadow King psychic defenses represented
by these two characters trying to stop
David from penetrating his mind in
locating him like he says the Shadow
King is hiding from me the fact that
it's a dance battle is just the director
and the creator's way of visualizing
their psychic battle because this is all
happening in the astral plane so if you
wondered why they suddenly broke into
song and dance in why all the lights
started flashing behind them that is
them having their full-blown wizard
battle but the real cool thing that they
do this season is they let you know what
the stakes are the goal by the end of
the season right away so we have a very
clear track to the finale Shadow King
looking for his body they need to stop
him because of the shadow Kings
consciousness rejoins with his body
he'll be unstoppable will address the
crazy twist at the end of the episode
because that's all about what's going on
with this new Admiral character who I
know everybody has a lot of questions
about but they just want to show you how
there's conflicts within the group and
conflict between the characters outside
of this overarching conflict with the
shadow king so shadow king is still the
main villain of the season but within
each characters arc they have a conflict
with another character like sid says
you're keeping secrets from me so
there's even a conflict between the two
of them because he's really trying to do
what future Sid wants him to do
but present-day Sid doesn't know
anything about that so she's really
pissed off but at the center of it
you have David who's trying to defeat
the Shadow King without killing Oliver
which is what section three is trying to
do they'll kill the Shadow King at any
cost
even if it means destroying all of her
his body which is what I think that
post-credits scene and CID from the
future was talking about when she says
you need to help him find his body I
think that's because they want to
separate him from all of hers body so
that they can fight the Shadow King and
defeat him without having to kill Oliver
because looping it back around to all of
hers wife who was doing all the drugs
during the episode she looked completely
off her rocker and if you weren't sure
what was going on with that crazy
bird-like creature that was wheeling
past her that was another representation
of what you could call this black goo
creature the delusion that Foster's in
someone's mind so she's got this
full-blown delusion it probably gets
worse something terrible happens because
Oliver probably ends up dying in this
original version of the timeline so CID
from the future probably came back to
tell David you need to help find a way
to defeat the Shadow King that doesn't
involve Oliver dying so David is sort of
caught between these two camps everybody
in present-day he wants to do the right
thing
fight the shadow king but he also has to
wrestle with the idea that he has to
help the Shadow King because the current
path that they're on only leads to
something even worse but hopefully that
explains what that post-credit scene was
about that was probably the biggest
question I got is like where was he for
a year so the basic premise is that when
he got sucked up into that sphere that
was sent by CID from the future he
actually left the sphere went to help
the shadow king so when they say that
Oliver had popped up and there were
sightings all over the world in the past
year
David was with him David can teleport
the Shadow King cannot so just a
reminder they tried to tell you what
everyone's abilities are and they had
this big montage at the beginning of the
episode they sort of let you know what
was going on if you haven't watched the
episodes in a while but in the comics
David has thousands of different powers
on the TV show the only ones we've seen
so far is telepathy telekinesis in
teleportation so he has all the ultimate
treasure hunter abilities they can
search people's minds to try and find
traces of where the body might be in
teleport instantaneously but because his
mind is so fragile
and because he's operating with the
Shadow King on so many different psychic
levels he's starting to get lost within
the maze of his mind so he's a very
unreliable narrator so if you're
confused about the series it's because
it's being told largely from David's
perspective and he's not always sure
what's going on so that's why we as the
audience as we watch things play out
aren't totally sure what's going on
the set design was amazing we could talk
all day about how amazing the series
just looks the way that they film it the
set design the costumes and the way that
they use that within episodes to tell
you what's going on with the characters
give you an idea for where their head
spaces and make you feel disoriented
like when David's talking to the Admiral
but he has the staircase behind him that
sort of a visual metaphor for the
staircase of his mind winding down
deeper levels into his psyche the best
metaphor that I could give for the
Admiral character is that he's kind of a
Trask figure someone who's good wants to
stop the villain but really doesn't care
about mutant kind
he said flat out that he's going to
exterminate all of her at any cost we
need to do anything we can to stop the
shadow king from getting his body of
course we have to mention the female
mustaches they're basically androids
like part human part machine but they
have one psyche that's all sort of
linked collectively he uses them to
communicate probably is a defense
mechanism so that other people like
David can't read his mind the creator
said the reason he wears that basket on
his head is to show that he has no ego
there was an ancient Chinese general in
the real world that wore one so he's
doing that to show that he's not an
egotistical person that's only in it for
more power that pretty much covers most
of it talking about Amahl Farouk though
this character looks much more like
comic book
Amahl Farouk I don't know about this
actor here he just seems to mic a more
polished version of that character so I
think when they find his body by the end
of the season this is what the body will
actually look like even though he's
inhabited so many different minds across
the years remember he's from the 1800s
so he's been alive for a long time
before Charles Xavier trapped him on the
astral plane talking a little bit more
about the Professor X of it all Patrick
Stewart did say last year that he was
totally gamed to come on the show I
don't know what plans they've made they
did say that they would push deeper into
his origin but just remember if we do
see professor X on the TV show you
probably wind up being Patrick Stewart I
feel like that would be more rewarding
to the fans than seeing James McAvoy an
old man makeup but the really big Easter
Egg to Jon Hamm doing the voiceover for
this series Jon Hamm was actually going
to be mr. sinister during the New
Mutants movie that's right they were
gonna do mr. sinister but then there was
a report that the Dark Phoenix movie
separately from that was actually gonna
do the mr. sinister character except
that it was gonna be the female miss
sinister gender bent character played by
Jessica Chastain because she's gonna be
the main villain of Dark Phoenix what'll
probably happen is is because last
season just Legion wasn't super popular
on my channel we'll see how this video
does and at the very least I will do a
video for every couple of episodes and
definitely one for the finale like I did
last season so no worries and the same
thing is gonna happen with Krypton so
I'm not going to be doing another
Krypton episode video for a little while
but if they do something really big then
I'll do a bonus video for that and I
know there's still like a ton of Legion
questions like I only talked about brief
parts of the episode so post all your
questions in the comments below but
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new Deadpool cancer
trailer and click here for brand new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]